o jovem à primeira vista
a notícia parece que alguém ligado
compenetrado em si mesma água que se
isola no seu mundo e nunca saí de lá ela
é alguém que não tem interesse em
conhecer as ilhas ao redor mas
observando ele mais de perto a gente
percebe que há sim interesse em conhecer
o mundo ao redor existe e só então
talvez não consiga manifestar isso de
uma forma clara
ele quer conhecer as ilhas ao redor da
sua porém os meios que ele tem os seus
recursos que permitem pra isso às vezes
são recursos falhos são recursos
ineficientes por exemplo o barco dele
pode estar furado pode estar com remo
relembrá-lo o elenco ele não sabia nadar
ele não consegue desviar os perigos do
alto mar
sim e por causa dessas dificuldades que
eu enfrentei em 30 na jornada bm sua
jornada ele acaba tomando a atitude e
isolá lo de volta não só ele se recolher
então diria que ele não é humilhado ele
é um naufragado
entretanto alguns autistas com sede em
superar essa dificuldade interna da
navegação lá fazendo o contrário
atraindo as pessoas pra ele e dele se
ele não sair até a ilha faz as outras
filhas irem até ele e esse foi o meu
caso eu nasci uma eu sabia desde criança
eu era muito diferente de todas as
outras pessoas
eu sempre tive bastante dificuldade de
me comunicar de falar sobre o que eu
penso explicar com clareza sobre os
sentimentos as minhas ideias
então sempre tive bastante dificuldade
para manter a fazer é manter amizades
mas quando eu pegava um papel e
desenhava as pessoas prestavam atenção
em quem as pessoas paravam pra prestar
atenção no meio da minha habilidade e
talento artístico então talento
artístico foi o recurso que eu usei pra
[Música]
navegar pelos oceanos
a propósito o desenho w
esses primeiros desenhos da história
foram feitos por mim seja sabia que eu
tinha essa dificuldade pra falar então
resolvi ser aquela pessoa que alguém
pergunta entendeu que desenho
eu desenho
[Aplausos]
tá eu só falo por final por favor não só
isso levanta outra questão
eu sou artista porque isso autista não
vou contar um pouco da minha história
pra responder melhor só pergunta essa
questão
então desde criança eu comecei a
desenhar acredito com a maioria dos
desenhos profissionais
eu gostava muito de ver desenhos
animados nem quadrinhos jogar videogame
eu tenho usado em reproduzir no papel os
personagens com um meu traço continua
presente
eu também na scar encatho que o original
e com o tempo um tempo eu fui criando os
meus próprios personagens
eu me formei na faculdade de artes um
emprego em uma empresa relacionada com
um desenho sempre na área de desenho e
ilustração de material didático e
participar de evento de quadrinhos e
games
então sempre tive uma afinidade maior
com um dos desenhos nem sempre entende
as pessoas direito mas o desenho tinha
uma lógica que fazer mais sentido pra
mim uma lógica previsível simples
coerente
por exemplo o desenho animado com o
quadrinho gente meus 55 em seus
personagens sempre consegue identificar
quem é o herói ou vilão
ele sempre tem o mesmo emprego mora no
mesmo lugar tem os mesmos amigos elas
mesmas frases
mas mas não das pessoas já o contrário
disso é imprevisível complexo incoerente
as pessoas mudam de emprego não ficar
muito longe e cidade é só explicar que o
jogador de futebol quando fica famoso
nem muda de time
as pessoas as pessoas mudam a pessoas
não se as características ao longo do
tempo com os desenhos ela se você não
tem o mesmo padrão em personagem que tem
50 100 anos elas continuam do mesmo
jeito
o desenho sol resolveu usar o desenho
com a minha pós com o das pessoas só
tinha o seguinte eu não gostava muito de
desenhar pessoas
eu sempre queria desenhar personagens
indicar um personagem de desenho animado
de quadrinhos só com os empregos que o
time no colégio sempre passava até mesmo
pela mesma situação as pessoas meus
colegas até alguns professores até meus
chefes têm que me pediu para fazer o
desenho deles é a reação que a maioria
das pessoas tem diante uma de alguém que
sabe desenhar pedir para fazer o desenho
não resolvesse investir nisso em
caricatura mostra que os 27 e 28 anos
estou com 36 agora então ea caricatura
foi uma forma de trazer as pessoas do
mundo dos desenhos da pessoa tanto para
transformá la num desenho aumentar
aumentar a afinidade com elas
depois comecei a trabalhar com
caricatura para aprender a conversar com
as pessoas e atender clientes e esse
trabalho também e os empregos fixos eu
ficava sempre nas mesmas ilhas
clientes na caricatura como trabalhar em
lugares diferentes
esse lugar isso trabalhei pra ir pra
empresas de vários setores
em um desses trabalhos o conhecia e
pessoas da área da saúde como uma pessoa
que ela falou geórgia de autistas
observando meu jeito de falar ou seja
observando meu minha postura e falou
sobre essa esse tema e eu nunca tinha
ouvido falar antes síndrome de asperger
quando pesquisei sobre isso na internet
foi uma epifania normalmente e de novo
na minha vida como se fosse um
extraterrestre que descobriu que é de
outro planeta
sua vida inteira morando em outro
planeta está aqui então que essa
descoberta da minha condição de e
pessoas com síndrome de asperger um tipo
de autismo leve significou dá pra se
para a ciência para os médicos é um tipo
de autismo leve que prefere ter
principalmente em texto 13 pontos
o défice de dificuldade com o traquejo
social da comunicação verbal e corporal
interesse muito restrita em diversos
temas explicar porque eu gostava tanto
de desenhos e um pensamento muito lógico
muito linear muito concreto seja tudo
sem ter um início meio e fim
só do homem explicar porque me sentia
tão confortável com os desenhos foi
descoberto tem muito mais gente que é
igual a mim num sentir parte da mesma
ilha também foi má fé foi um retorno
quando tive diagnóstico tardio uma
descoberta foi na minha idade adulta
vamos sentir como se eu tivesse e passar
a minha vida caminhando por uma estrada
por um destino errado por exemplo como
se eu quisesse ir lá pro amazonas
tivesse indo lá pra
a pernambuco e todo mundo que já fez uma
viagem sabe pra fazer o retorno até o
ponto certo do leva algum tempo então
muita coisa que eu o que as pessoas têm
autismo aprendem num na infância na
adolescência eu confesso que só aprende
depois de adulto
depois dessa descoberta ou conhece
outras pessoas com autismo e outras
pessoas autistas outra os pais de
autistas méxico os autistas professores
de autistas e contando eles me contando
a história deles
oi apesar de serem pessoas diferentes
com formações diferentes interesses
diferentes e sempre achei bastante
interessante pontos em comum com a minha
história por exemplo não tem amigos
sofrer bullying na escola não gostar não
conseguiu por meio de tubos partida
assim nessa descoberta desse contato com
outros autistas e resolvi abraçar a
causa do ativismo para o autismo e
conheci várias diretores e ongs apronte
smo a dersa andré monteiro me ajudou a
fazer caricaturas em público porque
antes eu só fazia gols em casa
o projeto deu tão certo que ela deu a
idéia e quer criar um livro com os meus
desenhos um moroso sul também graças ao
nosso trabalho com os que encontrar uma
outra notícia mais famosa do mundo
também foi palestrante do ted temple
grandin com e esse trabalho de ativismo
aprendi várias coisas a primeira é
autista nunca é igual ao outro que estão
algumas fotos de artistas famosos que
cada um tem uma habilidade diferente
tempo por exemplo da área de isopor e
zootecnia
john robinson engenheiro eletrônico e
distritais do kiss
susan boyle muitos de vocês conhecem em
março e também existe autista surfista
ou seja ou seja autista podem ser
parecidos nesse ponto que eu falei por
interesse muito muito forte alguma coisa
os interesses nem sempre vai ser a mesma
coisa vai ter o autista mais um mais
comprometido que não fala com consegue
serviço direito que consegue se virar
sozinho ao sistema depende mais
independente
daí a razão do meu diagnóstico tardio
também que muitos médicos acharam que
ainda acham que só existe o autismo
grave um severo
outra coisa que aprendi eu tenho desse
deficiente é usado para quem enxerga
holanda com as próprias pernas
um ouve a todo mundo é deficiente alguma
coisa essa realidade pessoa que não sabe
desenhar pessoa que não sabe dirigir não
sabe cozinhar não sabe falar inglês
ela também tem a ver com a deficiência e
todas as pessoas têm algum interesse
restrito à profissão que a gente escolhe
para a nossa vida é de certa forma nosso
interesse restrito
o assunto do qual a gente sempre fala
nas nossas conversas engenharia elétrica
construção civil medicina direito o tpi
maioria das nossas conversas também é
dominado por um pela nossa profissão é a
descoberta mais importante a meu ver
ao meu ver essas são as três esferas que
me define a do artista rodrigo autista
outro artista rodrigo autista ea pessoa
rodrigo tramonte por causa desse
interesse e profecia hiperfoco interesse
muito intenso um desenho autismo
eu consegui fazer sucesso nessas duas
áreas de cima
só que a área pessoa com rodrigo
tramonte da minha pessoa espera da minha
pessoa acabou ficando em segundo plano
diria que em último plano
e então conseguiu tempo tornar um
desenho está famoso com quem me tornar
um ativista para autismo famoso
só que quando a pessoa fica você sabe
que quando a pessoa fica famosa como
pessoa vira um gênio da arte um gênio da
ciência acaba de editar música acaba
virando um personagem caíram 11 pessoas
enxergam nele como 2011 como nome não
vai no banheiro alguém só fica é
desenhado só fica trabalho cantando só
fica praticando esporte como aconteceu
com elvis michael jackson o pelé então
isso aí certa forma também aconteceu
comigo eu focar nas caricaturas
totalmente dedicado à caricatura também
tornando uma caricatura de mim mesmo
muita gente mostrou que vem falar comigo
não pergunta como eu tô no perguntas e
elton
eu estou fazendo de novo só perguntam se
eu estou desenhando então contam os
desenhos não contar o rodrigo tem isso
aqui também
depois do dado sucesso com a sua lista
para autismo
muita gente principalmente as mães
começaram a enxergar como um super-herói
autismo
ou seja alguém que pegou a habilidade ou
para superar a dificuldade só que uma
coisa que um dos desenhos ensina sobre o
super-herói e quitou todos super herói
tem a sua identidade secreta
então é essa aqui é a minha identidade
o rodrigo tramonte
[Aplausos]
o pão
eu vim aqui
eu consegui alcançar seu destino nas
estradas do da um artista do autista mas
a estrada do rodrigo tramonte eu ainda
estou fazendo retorno
agora que eu conheço minha verdadeira
essência verdadeira personalidade no
verdadeiro sentido de uma forma de
funcionar
agora eu tô conseguindo superar as
dificuldades dessa nessa auto-estrada
também quando você encontra um autista
11 uma pessoa diferente você um cego
surdo cadeirante
decidi focar na eficiência de colocar
aquilo que ele colocar aquilo que é
diferente você pra criar essa ilha
fizesse a ponte precisa focar na
semelhança que a pessoa tente comum
contigo ela também gosta de cozinhar
também gosta e jogar futebol é negócio
filme de terror
preciso focar na semelhança muito
obrigado a fazer gracinha
[Aplausos]